[Musik]
abenteuer dhaulagiri auf den spuren
schweizer himalaya pioniere
dhaulagiri
wasserwerk am nordost grad suchen vier
schert haus die zelte von camp 2
es ist die kopie
expeditionsleiter riebold ahnt was kommt
nach schweren wochen am berg ist der
schweizer expeditionsleiter am ende
seiner kräfte
[Musik]
wir haben keine power mehr
ich werde nochmals der familien für das
1 aber wahrscheinlich werden die
expedition aufbrechen
[Musik]
in den 1950 er jahren versuchten
bergsteiger aus aller welt den
dhaulagiri zu erobern
sieben expeditionen scheiterten unter
oftmals dramatischen umständen
zwei bergsteiger kamen dabei ums leben
dann ausgerechnet an einem freitag den
13 schaffte eine schweizer expedition
die erstbesteigung
die bilder gingen um die welt zwei
schweizer zwei nepalesen ein deutscher
und ein österreicher auf dem gipfel
ihres erfolgs
zwei der damaligen helden waren ernst
forrer und peter die immer aus wildhaus
das sind die protect ratsherr thomas
absolut
für mich nicht groß wie in anderen
akteuren man aber haben wir bis hat die
knie aber da bin in mein gesicht
uns natürlich ganz anders
seit seiner besteigung 1960 gehört der
dhaulagiri auch ein wenig den schweizern
und so macht sich 50 jahre danach einmal
mehr eine schweizer expedition auf zum
weißen berg
[Musik]
unter den teilnehmern sind auch die
erstbesteiger ernst forrer und albin
schelbert sowie hugo weber sie sind die
ehrengäste der jubiläums expedition die
sich auf die spuren von schweizer
himalaya pionieren macht
von kathmandu aus geht's zehn stunden
lang über eine holprige straße nach
dabei am eingang des neuen details
der expeditionsleiter richi bolt kommt
aus alten der dhaulagiri ist sein
siebter achttausender
bevor er den gipfel besteigen kann muss
er die trecker und bergsteiger zum
basislager führen
erfahrungen aus mit dem die ganze
vegetations stufe durchwandern und die
hand da ist eigentlich ein optimales
akklimatisation der schein gelungen ist
und die landesmesse über haben es macht
sinn dass man nicht damit
sinnlos der vag gemeinsam den pda und es
ist für alle eigentlich versehen gesund
so sah als erster bergsteiger
französische alpinisten den dhaulagiri
im jahre 1950 sie hielten ihn jedoch für
teufel schwierig und zu gefährlich und
kehrt nun nach den franzosen versuchten
mehrere expeditionen den
8167 meter hohen gipfel zu erreichen
vergebens und mit jedem gescheiterten
versuch wuchs das interesse der
öffentlichkeit am dhaulagiri auf dem
stein gletscher am sustenpass haben die
mitglieder der kommenden schweizerischen
dhaulagiri expedition in einem
trainingslager fertigkeiten geübt die
ihnen im eislabyrinth des höchsten noch
unbeschriebenen himalaya riesen zugute
kommen werden
die franzosen hatten mit der annapurna
den ersten achttausender geschafft die
briten mit dem everest den höchsten die
schweizer 1956 mit dem lhotse nur den
vierthöchsten
einer der bergsteiger am susten bau max
eiselin aus luzern die besten indem sie
den damals der nacht
durchsichtige den total 4 bestehen
feiert der dhaulagiri
um ihr schweizer hin bis dato
nur eine halbe stelle der lotse unter
druck stehende zweite wurde
1958 machte sich die dritte schweizer
expedition auf zum dhaulagiri
in zürich haben sich fünf mitglieder der
neu und schweizer himalaya expedition
reisefertig gemacht
letztes karten studium mit dem
expeditionsleiter wer maßstäblich der
mit max eiselin im flugzeug nachkommen
wird ein wimpel des akademischen
alpenclubs der schon 1953 am dhaulagiri
flatterte wird die expedition satz dr
winterhalter anvertraut ziel der
expedition ist der 8222 meter hohe noch
unbezwungene dhaulagiri
also ich habe vor zwei sachen angst
ich
konnte immer wieder vor dass einer unter
wechsel blinddarmentzündung überkommt
und die haben hier den blind an deshalb
user fortan heißt damit sich das sicher
nichts ändern will selber mit zwei
händen buch am blinddarm operiert und
gleichzeitig noch einmal größer machen
dass ein ding der unmöglichkeit sich
sehr schwierig uns zweite sind um fehler
oder vor irgendwelche tropenkrankheit
malaria oder wäre ich grüße sie aber
schwere unfälle mit mir ich noch übrig
wo der transport vor dem verletzten war
unglaublich schwierig sie
wie schwierig hatten 1954 die
argentinier erfahren ihr
expeditionsleiter francisco ibáñez zog
sich am dhaulagiri schwere erfrierungen
an den füßen und händen zu er konnte
wieder stehen noch gehen und musste von
seinen kameraden zwei wochen lang den
berg hinunter und durch das schier
endlosem eiern die tal getragen werden
bis nach kathmandu
im spital starb er an seinen
erfrierungen
kaspar winterhalter und seine kameraden
der reichsten 1958 mit dem auto nach
nepal
also autohändler schenkt überhol und
gesagt sie darf in den usa filmaufnahmen
für pr verwenden bp hat sich immer für
sämtliche benzinkosten auf so dass wir
praktisch gratis kreis interesse und
einmal hätte expeditionsleiter jedem
israels coca cola geschenk nämlich wo
man taj mahal ablagerten großzügig
muss der expedition kasse
in der nepalesischen bergstadt pokal
wurde das material auf 180 träger
verteilt
die coole händen möglichen
papiergeld also banknote als bezahlen
darum haben wir zwölf marken an dass der
berg ruft schleppten als münze
peter bofinger ist kino münze und da
nehmen wir ja alle paar tage die eu
zahlt
jeder dritte tag ist zahltag und die
kulisse erhalten das ihnen zugewiesene
rutschen klingende münze etwa 353 den
tag was für sie ein fürstliches gehalt
bedeutet die haben immer denkt man jetzt
zwei verdiente mit den münzen
ab 6 dann findet man
hier bis passiert sehr ehrlich
wahnsinnig ersatz bereit und eigentlich
fasching und fröhlich
ja
juni ist das eine enorm anstrengen die
zig sie will mich jeden tag seine mama
lacht und läufer
und denn wenn man alkohol ist ein ort wo
man hat wellen über machte es sind immer
schon los im dorf sie will sie wissen
wie oder küsten das bin expedition ist
immer der doktor und der doktor bin
technik sie den hunger also die
verschiedene sache dort behandelt sehr
versucht diagnose zu machen oder aber
natürlich mit einfachen hilfsmitteln und
den eltern erzieher sind alico mit zwei
oder noch mehr russ und dass ich
wahnsinnig alarmiert will das heißt es
hält das wohl am berg tobt nur andere
schlank muskulös und den hunger also
alles gemacht fluglinien operationen
über geburtshilfe und dann
gegen mitternacht und am zweitmarkt
fertig sie seien auf dem rückweg
meistens wenn sie rohes einstellte und
ein wenig auf die finnin der im hinkampf
mit rache und auf die siebenmeter
marschiert es ist also sehr steinig
der weg zum dhaulagiri führt wie damals
durch dass man total
185 kilometer langes rauf und runter
etwa in der mitte des tropischen tals
liegt das dorf muri
[Musik]
dann auf 2500 meter das dorf der bahn
nach der waldgrenze geht es weiter auf
3700 meter zum italien basecamp
dann weitere 1000 meter hinauf zum
dollar geary basecamp dem ausgangspunkt
für den gipfel versuch der jubiläums
expedition
die teilnehmer sind inzwischen zwei tage
unterwegs es ist heiß staubig und steil
[Musik]
hier geht die vorteile die
ja
nach weiteren drei tagen durch den
dschungel hat sich die expedition dogan
dem hintersten dorf im tal
auf dem dorfplatz veranstalten die
einwohner eine kleine feier zu ehren der
drei pioniere des dhaulagiri
[Musik]
wenn sie sich so lang hart dass die
überhaupt das wissen wir sind die meiste
gewalt bei uns das ist
kein beruf sicherung
[Musik]
nach der bahn geht es nur noch zu fuß
weiter
faultier würde diesen steg betreten
[Musik]
dann windet sich der schmale pfad
unbarmherzig die wände hinauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die gesetzlich zugelassene last pro
träger beträgt heute wie früher 30 kilo
der tageslohn 10 franken etwa gleich
viel verdient ein nepalesischer lehrer
auf gut 4500 metern der höhe des
matterhorns passiert expeditionsleiter
riebold mit den veteranen jene stelle wo
einst die ersten bergsteiger ihr
basislager aufgeschlagen hatten über
diesen hang die sogenannte birnen route
versuchten diese damals den weißen berg
zu erreichen
dass sich ganze laden gejagt von
expedition seas ist europäisches
expedition civil mit einer viererkette
mit energie seriellen uhr fand das spiel
sehr groß aber es anders
sein die komfortorientierte
und dazumal ist einfach um
materialien ort zu den berg ist auch in
europa
bestiegen bezwingen bedingt der bestieg
war es möglich wenn store laut und das
ist von einem herzlichen bis
nach einigen wochen am berg erreichte
expedition arzt kaspar winterhalter
lager
30 metern ein richtiger klimatisiert und
sind dann also zwei oder drehbuch auf
der höhe und einzug und verklebte sich
mann vom teilelager treibt aber bis ins
basislager
lions lagen zwei abgeladen wir heute ein
tagungs kritisch widerruf und der abruf
und habt das zeug für den gipfelsturm
an ort schaffen
auf 6700 metern befand sich das so
genannte öl endlager dort hatten die
schweizer eine höhle ins ausgegraben
darin fanden sie schutz und wärme
vom höhlen lager aus ging es weiter
hinauf zu einer birnen ähnlichen steilen
felswand
dort befestigten sie ihre zelte auf
stelzen aus aluminium
die haben das also mit
bedenken haben das zur kenntnis aber wir
müssen feststellen dass wenn es nicht
traurig luft jetzt auch mal ganz gut
wenn sie natürlich luft immer bizarrer k
ob mir fiel auf dass sie nicht nur natur
bergab flügel aber mehr handys als
separate holger pütz türkei mit den raum
gesichert also abgestützt werden wäre
mehr oberhand
fünf monate nach beginn der expedition
unternahmen die bergsteiger einen
letzten versuch den gipfel zu erreichen
sie kommen gut voran
dann stießen sie kurz vor dem ziel auf
eine einfache keine 200 meter hohe fels
partie
in nur 200 meter bis zum gipfel und den
200 meter und damit nur das konkret muss
man muss sehr schöne und wenn der wind
mit über 100 kilometer
- 10 und 12 grad kann man einfach nicht
ohnehin schon wieder machen zum sieht
man hier über die entstehung 123 mal
passiert wenn es ein oder zwei tag nicht
so schaurig bloß wersau gurk sie aber
dass es hat jetzt halt nicht sollen sein
gerät kaufte mehrere dass kraft
aber für mich ist das komisch mehr
hätten zeige wie gar nicht so viel los
gemacht dass man es nicht schafft hat
welche denn es fällt mir kein muster
krone jeder hat alles gepasst hat und
wenn scott ist gut und wenn es nicht
gott ist jedenfalls abend über sie
die rückkehr führte über den franzosen
pass von dort aus kann man den
dhaulagiri gut sehen am franzosen pass
studierte der luzerner max eiselin den
berg und entdeckte den nordost grad
diese route sollte ihm zwei jahre später
zum erfolg führen
da habe ich sehe dass das so genannte im
nordost sparen sich eigentlich auf trank
ich eigentlich immer verzaubert
wetter schön schnee und fern k wird die
zahl trainer platzieren er hat auch noch
nordost arktis mit so stark im westturm
ausgesetzt sehe ja dem speisesaal
website die schlacht gute das er getan
ortmann vom dhaulagiri
und die gute serie der bianconeri
unter der leitung von max eiselin
startete im märz 1960 die vierter
dhaulagiri expedition unter schweizer
leitung
erstmals wurde ein flugzeug eingesetzt
unter den auserkorenen bergsteigern
befand sich auch der ostdeutsche kletter
pionier peter diener
dann kommt max eiselin den thalia wieder
über plan und wir sind doch keine tabus
das ist natürlich ganz grosse moment ist
vorüber war curry dan marks räte du
peter hedges luft mit skonto ag und da
will ich meinen die träume und dann
tatsächlich hat er mich dann in die
realität so kalt und wittendorf erzählt
obwohl es also 1960 noch mal probieren
auf eine neue route wo er damals 58 tod
von ted könnte erfolgversprechend sie
ein solches er dann aber wurde
peter diener war wenige jahre zuvor aus
der ddr geflohen in der schweiz von der
arbeit und anschluss an die kletterszene
mit aufsehenerregenden erstbesteigungen
in den alpen qualifizierte er sich für
neben
empfangs mystischen
charakter katos das ferne land das
verborgene land in asien
das ist niemals klitschko jeder hier
reisen und erhöht auch jeder
gut fühlt die nötige fitness und nötige
geld
kaufen achten dass sich das einfach ganz
besonderes erlebnis kino
nach neun tagen erreicht die jubiläums
expedition das basislager auf 4650 meter
über meer
die erstbesteiger haben ihr ziel
erreicht
für den jungen bergsteiger benjamin
fängt das abenteuer erst an
hoffen
sie dass ich total von jahreszahlen und
das überhaupt derart wird und jetzt der
doppelspiel unser werk lief sie
auf jeden fall
tweed robert spaltet aber das ist nicht
wenig schaffen höhere und auch die vita
ich mach dir mal vor sie vom campus spaß
und zerschmettert energiequellen french
kolja ich wahnsinnige niedrig vor allem
dennis
und da das blieb schon jetzt gut das ist
jetzt
nicht
auf
von oben betrachtet sieht das basislager
aus wie winzige punkte im schutz von
dort aus führt die route über den
gefürchteten eisbruch dass man die
gletschers auf 5700 metern folgt der
sattel der sogenannte nordost gold von
dort geht es über den steilen nordost
grad bis zum gipfel
1959 schafften es die österreicher bis
auf 7800 meter
das war die ausgangslage als ein jahr
später die schweizer in kathmandu
landeten
am zwanzigsten märz 1960 landet der yeti
erstmals auf den großen parade platz
inmitten der stadt kathmandu mit sechs
expedition skaten an bord hat er die
schweiz acht tage zuvor verlassen und
ist über italien griechenland syrien
irak person pakistan indien nach nepal
geflogen gegen 20 tausend neugierige
wollen zeugen der ankunft sein und ein
halbes her kulka soldaten muss der yeti
vor dem ansturm schützen
max eiselin expedition mannschaft
bestand aus schweizern polen deutschen
und dem österreicher kurt diemberger der
im himalaya drei finger verlor die
amberger ist der einzige leben der
alpinist dem die erstbesteigung zwei
achttausender gelangen
es war eine schweizer expedition aber
sie war international dem max eiselin
ist es gelungen 30 jahre vor der eu
schon die europäische seilschaft auf die
beine zu stellen und das ist nun
wirklich etwas großartiges gewesen
und nun ist der große augenblick
gekommen start zur ersten landung im
himalaya
5000 meter höhe oben werden wir leben
und die tropische hitze wird eine kälte
von bis zu 35 grad und erreichen
auf dem 5200 meter hohen damms spaß es
befand sich das so genannte art
klimatisierungs lager
oben das sind der ernst und ich
ausgestiegen
und haben gesagt ja ich habe gar nicht
so schlimm die luft ist gut
und habe gesagt jetzt fangen wir halt
einmal diese gäste herzurichten
ich habe auf der einen seite gearbeitet
und der ernsthaft anhäufung gesehen der
neigt sich schon und dann hörst dich
dann auch schon
und man hat also wenn man so lange
zunächst einmal genug sauerstoff im blut
und das hätte vielleicht eine halbe
stunde oder so und dann wird's aber da
wird einem wunderheiler
nach einigen tagen im akklimatisierung
lager wurden die ersten bergsteiger von
kampusch passaus weiterer 500 meter
hinauf geflogen
[Musik]
der landeplatz befand sich über dem
gefürchteten ausbruch des mayon die
gletschers am fuße des dhaulagiri
die landung ist gelungen freudig
gratulieren wir unseren piloten ernst
sagte hat er damit doch einen weltrekord
erreicht
die expedition verlief gut bis zu dem
tag als das flugzeug abstürzte die
piloten blieben unverletzt und konnten
ins tal hinunter steigen die bergsteiger
waren von nun an auf sich allein
gestellt
wir haben nicht wissen können nicht
erfahren keine funkverbindung nichts
gehabt dieser jetzt ist nicht mehr
gekommen
dann haben wir gesagt ja
vielleicht sind die chinesen
einmarschiert und haben das flugzeug
beschlagnahmt oder was aber was da auch
immer sei wir werden schon noch
absteigen aber zuerst machen wir denn da
reagieren
vor schelbert dierberger schavan und
niemand ort befanden sich am nordost
grund
ist was los ist die armeeführung kann ja
überhaupt nicht nur und dann nach
amerika ausgelöst also der werkzeuge und
anlagen im lager aufbauen also
zählt und als material an mich selber
müssen ertragen
doch das ist schon hart aber ich glaube
jede mit sich selber beschäftigt da hätt
an der serie halten trieb die ganz
konkret an der viele regen der bisher
nur ein körperliches und da muss mit der
hansestadt die gräber dass es ganz
flüssig bleibt ist
schade dass das magnetisch klingt
gehören und dass der kleinere motor
warm werden denn er hat nur jemand bis
daimler geguckt haben die trauben hoffen
können
sie hatte schnitte panik liga getan die
mannschaft sage sie besser
als das flugzeug abstürzte befand sich
die zweite gruppe am tempo spaß von dort
mussten sie zu fuß und schwer beladen
durch das verlorene tal zum french goll
dem franzosen pass von dort runter zum
basislager
dann wieder hoch zum sattel dem nordost
ghosn
zwei wochen nach dem absturz des
flugzeugs war das team wieder beisammen
der jurassier hugo weber
expeditionsleiter max eiselin der im
zelt pressemeldungen schrieb
der basler albin schelbert und kurt
diemberger der österreicher
der toggenburger ernst forrer und sein
kletterpartner peter diener
als ein paar großen respekt davor
nachdem massa sieht der expeditionen vor
reese mit luther gut ablief sind oder
sie muss und wer respektvoll
dort
angegangen
zur vorbereitung auf den gipfel gehört
auch eine sogenannte pusher diese
zeremonie haben einst die sherpas eigens
für die fremden alpinisten erfunden
[Musik]
der aufstieg über den bayern die
gletscher ist auch heute noch schwierig
und gefährlich in den steilen traversen
traunstein und eis schlag
[Applaus]
in dieser gletscher ebene befand sich
einst ein zwischenlager die bergsteiger
stiegen frühjahr pro tag etwa 500
höhenmeter heute bewältigen sie doppelt
so viel
täglich donnern staub lawinen den berg
hinunter sie sind eine große gefahr das
gleiche gilt für gletscherspalten
1959 stürzte der wiener bergsteiger
heinrich reuß 20 meter tief wieder eine
enge gletscherspalte
als ihn seine kameraden stunden später
fanden vernahmen sie nur noch ein leises
stöhnen
sein grab war das erste am dhaulagiri
meine ich sage mir sind da geht nichts
pkw der
motor so extrem gott wo man ja auch
mitunter führt rechnen deshalb ist
passiert aber irgendwie blendet man das
einfach nur
angst nicht einfach
spanisch hat einfach nie loslassen jetzt
der nächste tag
expeditionsleiter riebold und benjamin
haben den maria gletscher bald geschafft
lager 1 befindet sich auf 5700 metern
unweit der stelle wo jeweils das
flugzeug landete
jetzt halt nichts warm
sherpa sharing angebote dokumentiert mit
seiner kamera den alltag dieser besteht
wie eh und je aus gehen essen und ruhen
wichtigstes thema ist das wetter wie
immer am berg
was sagen sie zu den wetterbedingungen
viel schnee
ja ja ja
[Musik]
am morgen steigen die sherpas in
richtung camp zwei
museen ich stampfen sie einen pfad in
den schnee
wie so oft am dhaulagiri ist das wetter
am morgen sonnig und klar gegen mittag
ziehen wolken auf und am nachmittag
fällt schnee
die wetteraussichten sind schlecht an
einen weiteren aufstieg ist nicht zu
denken die windfahne hängt über dem
gipfel des weißen berg schön und
bedrohlich
am abend sind wieder alle im basislager
und warten auf besseres wetter
der erfolg am dhaulagiri ging schon
immer vom wetter ab das erfuhren 1959
die österreicher
das unglück ihres kameraden sollte ihren
wie sie sagten angriff auf den
dhaulagiri entscheidend verzögern
wenn die reise sind eine gletscherspalte
gefallen dann mussten sie denn natürlich
erst noch begraben weit unten das alles
hat so viel zeit gekostet das inzwischen
der monsun dahergekommen ist es uns
fürchterlicher stürme und dann haben sie
eben auf 7800 meter höhe vielleicht war
es auch weniger den falschen drehen
müssen drei tage lang hintereinander
haben sie es versucht
cassandra lama der berühmte apathie am
dhaulagiri dreimal hoch oben gewesen ist
er war verzweifelt
mit tränen in den augen hatte gesagt die
götter wollen nicht dass ihren wohnsitz
betreten
und hier hatte das klingt sie hatten
dieses glück es war ein sagt baris
unglaubliches glück dieser 13 immer
als die bergsteiger zum letzten gipfel
gang aufbrauchen hatten sie bereits
wichtige erfahrungen gesammelt und hat
nun eine kühne strategie
hin haben wir schon am vierten gemacht
aber wir sind im schlechten dhaulagiri
weiter stecken geblieben auf 7800 meter
hat man nichts mehr gesehen und dann war
der sturm
haben wir gesagt wir müssen das tal
agiere wetter überlisten
nachdem auch am schönsten park ungefähr
vielleicht um 9 oder zähne dann die
wolken kommen und dann dauert es nicht
mehr lange dann schneit sondern sturm zu
diesem zeitpunkt müssen wir schon den
gipfel gemacht hat und daher müssen wir
einfach unseren ausgangspunkt zur sturm
lager höher setzen
um die mittagszeit können wir unsere
kameraden im feldstecher ganz deutlich
900 meter höher oben unter den
schützenden eis überhang von lage drei
erkennen hier hatten sie kurz mittags
last
[Musik]
zwei meter dick ist ein gericht die
fehler
die man über gross nicht links rechts
und so wird schon auch verbucht
[Musik]
drei tage ging es den nordost grad hoch
über die sogenannte himmelsleiter
[Musik]
am 12 mai erreichte die spitzengruppe 6
auf 7 1800 litern
das zelt befand sich gut geschützt unter
einem mächtigen felsblock
dort verbrachten die sechs bergsteiger
die nacht in einem einzigen zweier z
lima dort rechts im bild saß am
zelteingang und kochte ohne unterbruch t
für seine ausländischen klienten
am nächsten morgen war es sonnig und zum
ersten mal während der expedition
windstill
[Musik]
ich war in einem feuer heiß ich war an
dem tag in einer superform ich habe mir
gesagt es ist mir ganz klar der erste
der letzten geht die betrieb wird und
muss natürlich ein schweizer seien aber
solange soweit es überhaupt nur geht und
bis zu dem letzten vorgeblichen da mach
ich
dieses gelände auf
da die farbige protector artikel und
trauer unter schnee grata und der blaue
himmel reckt koller so passt in die
vorstellung von der todeszone
[Musik]
wir waren dann schon den gibt's nahe und
dann ist der ball bin hier gestanden und
hat gesagt mensch freue ich mich
gerade im richtigen augenblick da
sprachen in einem menschen in velen und
sg voraus
da ist er nur über einen schwierigen
blog geglättet
[Musik]
wie vor ort angeht verstand und hat im
werk um die pole und der leider durch
eigentlich erzählen oder habt ihr einen
schnellen und seine frau
wäre danke jetzt und das ist ja daran
mit oben bist also geschafft
es ist ein tag des glücks der 13
1960 ein freitag an dem unsere
13-köpfige expedition mannschaft das
vielen expeditionen verwehrt gewesene
ziel erreicht den dhaulagiri den 13
achttausender
ich mag mich erinnere hier nur ängstlich
geordert abschnitt durch emanuel
pogatetz nachricht
dann nicht das aber tatsächlich
rechte.de halben hätten den fels klotz
neue gefäß haken geschlagen und der
rebschnitt mit die verbunden so als teil
von unserer anwesenheit
wir haben ja gewusst von dem gipfel geht
so schnell nicht weg
wir haben uns also hingesetzt
wir haben uns hingelegt sogar in die
sonne rund um uns sind so wir wollten
dürfen aufgewachsen
50 jahre sind seither vergangen
doch wenn albin schelbert und hugo weber
mit ihrem expeditionsleiter max eiselin
sprechen verflüchtigt sich die zeit
hallo max
das handy gemacht dass er nicht nur froh
sind
sind immer
wieder hallten
expedition läuft ganz anders gehabt wie
vor 50 jahren
die welt jetzt ja gut
du bist ja nicht zum töten
am 13 bei dem fünfzigsten jahrestag der
erstbesteigung zwingt das wetter die
schweizer jubiläums expedition zum
warten
dies sind mit zu stoff unterwegs sieht
zwei unter seinem inhalt des koffers
themen sind ohne zusätzlichen sauerstoff
und sechs bedingungen sind sehr schlecht
opels sind extreme wind und ohne
sauerstoff nicht was schlichtweg zu
gefährlicher sich am mit stoff
also für wüste die partie sicher kein
thema
thema im lager sind die chinesen tier am
dhaulagiri sind die schweizer während an
diesem historischen tag ebenfalls gerne
zum gipfel hoch
ist
die herrin der risikos vortrag vor sich
sind so stoff und sehr stark die sherpas
bissig aber
temperatur werden sehr niedrig sie und
eigentlich ist das erzwingen vor dem
gipfel wo mit riesiger risiko verbunden
sind da heißt
wenn sich der gipfel schon
mal viel glück
und sehr wahrscheinlich
sehr große risiken eingegangen mit der
frühling und aber aus gesundheitlichen
schäden also
wenn sie sollten den gipfel erreichen
wird sind das samsung digital
organisatoren im basislager sind was mit
denen passiert ist und was mit deiner
abgegangen ist
am tag darauf sprechen schweizer
rettungshelikopter in die stille des
dhaulagiri 1
spezialisten der air zermatt bilden in
nepal rettungsmannschaften aus diese
fliegen ausgerechnet im umfeld des
jubiläumstages ihren ersten einsatz
die chinesische expedition erreichte den
dhaulagiri am 13 mai jedoch erst am
späten nachmittag
ein sturm zwang sie unterhalb des
gipfels zu biwakieren
dabei kamen drei bergsteiger ums leben
drei tage später warten die völlig
entkräfteten überlebende lamm grad
ohne hilfe hätten sie kaum eine chance
im falschen zeitpunkt schlechtes wetter
und das ist eine frage der erfahrung
und situation einschätzung
und das müssen wir jetzt gesehen
das ist das was niemand will
und wir hoffen dass wir das besser
machen
einmal mehr hat der weiße berg seine
opfer gefordert
seit der erstbesteigung 1960 erreichte
gut 400 bergsteiger den gipfel des
dhaulagiri
70 kamen ums leben
das heißt auf sechs gipfel erfolge kommt
im schnitt ein toter
gegen ende mai bricht die schweizer
jubiläums expedition zu ihrem
allerletzten versuch auf
am morgen sieht das wetter noch gut aus
doch dann setzt sich wieder das
gefürchtete dhaulagiri bett dadurch
auf 6600 metern höhe suchen die sherpas
vergebens nach den zelten von camp 2
der wind wird zum sterben
und der dhaulagiri
unmöglich zu erreichen
weiter unten realisiert das kleine
grüppchen dass der traum vom gipfel ein
traum bleiben wird
expeditionsleiter rische bolt hat alles
richtig gemacht jetzt ist er am ende
seiner kräfte der dhaulagiri hat ihn
zermürbt
wer für sie tragen
und den nächsten
von kuba begehen
wirklich nur hoffen kann dass
ich das ganze material dauernd materiale
studienlage zwei
tablets es geht ist ja leider nicht mir
ist aber gefährlich ist und wir haben
uns von anfang mit geschworen dass ich
hier keinen kleinen
ich glaube es ist richtig
[Musik]
das ist sehr hart für mich auch
persönlich
habe nicht extrem gefreut
hat mich sehr gut vorbereitet
das liegt
[Musik]
theologie ist auch eine option auch hier
so tritt nach zehn schweren wochen am
berg die schweizer jubiläums expedition
den rückzug an
der dhaulagiri erwies sich einmal mehr
als berg ohne gnade